serge sobreira bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors on le disait
mouvement de grève des éboueurs de cases
toute la semaine dernière c'était quoi
les raisons de ce ras-le-bol
alors juste pour apporter une précision
avant de commencer le débat
la grève n'est pas terminée elle est
reconductible et avec un préavis
jusqu'au dimanche 2 mai et elle a
commencé le 19 avril
voilà donc pour en revenir aux
fondamentaux de ce qui a déclenché la
clé les joueurs veulent de meilleurs des
meilleurs conditions de travail qui se
sont fortement dégradées au fil du temps
depuis je dirais le point d'amener est
donc venu de mettre le système de
collecte sont revenus aussi bien aux
manuels que mécanique il va le meilleur
une reconnaissance de la part de la
collectivité avec un meilleur au régime
indemnitaire aussi une participation de
la part de l'employeur au niveau de la
mutuelle santé alors ce que je rappelle
s est recentré notre fonction publique
territoriale aujourd'hui l'employeur
aura pour obligation d'ici 2026 de
participer à hauteur de 50 % sur la
partie santé pour l'habituelle et de 20%
pour la prévoyance
on demande un peu aujourd'hui bed
employeurs anticipent cette cette
ordonnance et petits sont obligatoires
en 2009 et 6 qui font ça il ya d'autres
collectivités aujourd'hui qu'ils le sont
pas voilà vous parler de conditions de
travail se sont fortement dégradées
depuis dix ans est ce qu'il ya des
difficultés supplémentaires à cause de
la crise sanitaire les difficultés
supplémentaires je dirais que le père au
quotidien qu'ils assurent les missions
de siorac de service public et une très
très bonne
un style qui remplissent alors les
difficultés supplémentaires elles elles
sont pas le dire je le dirai à la crise
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui depuis
le mois de mars 2000 2020 elles sont au
niveau de l'organisation et des tournées
ils sont organisés depuis pas mal
d'années déjà
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on fait tout
pour mécaniser ces collectes
on a sorti deux rippeurs c'est des
joueurs de derrière le camion où que ce
soit mécanisée cela fonctionne pas bien
et c'est un autre camion de lait du
personnel qui passe derrière le camion
mécanisée pour faire ce que n'a pas pu
faire le camion médicalisé quoi alors
votre profession un savon été déclarées
prioritaires pour la vaccination
on vous l'a proposé cette vaccination
aujourd'hui oui oui j'ai rencontré les
agents qui sont sur le terrain depuis le
19 parce que moi je fais pas partie de
cette collectivité
il me dit que l'employeur avait fait
passer par des nôtres de services la
possibilité d'aller se faire vacciner
on vaccine o drom qui a été organisée
par la ville de classe je suis triste
juste une précision
c'est le haut niveau de grève des agents
ne sont pas salariés uniquement de la
vie de nos castres c'est la communauté
d'agglomération castres mazamet voilà et
oui les albertains de ça pour aller se
faire vacciner parce que eux aussi
veulent baer retrouver une petit comme
on l'a connu tous et toutes en baisse
cette épidémie et surtout que les les
éboueurs n'ont jamais cessé de
travailler en ont parlé des caissières
ou les infirmières
du personnel hospitalier les éboueurs
ont toujours travaillé même depuis un an
pendant le premier confinement qui a été
très dur c'était la peur au ventre que
vous alliez travailler et si oui
pourquoi est il oui ici allez la peur au
ventre parce que c'était un virus qui
n'était pas connu et donc il savait pas
trop alors une attardée sur les les
chaînes sur les médias comment ça
pouvait se propager
donc ils ont fait très attention la
collectivité bien sûr à amiens place les
protocoles sanitaires helvétiques belle
virus se propage à sachin que lui aussi
est il le faudra parce qu'ils sont tous
les jours au quotidien plusieurs dans le
camion donc il faut qu'ils se protègent
eux-mêmes
oui oui c'est très très très très
impressionnant ce qu'ils font au
quotidien et ce travail au quotidien
pendant la crise est-ce qu'il a été
recueillie reconnu par le biais d'une
prime l'année dernière oui le président
a participé à hauteur de 16 les agents
qui étaient en première ligne et
notamment les éboueurs alors que les
époux vert comme d'autres corps de
métiers dans la fonction publique et
dans les trois versants de la fonction
publique de l'état ou hostiles
hospitalière il ya des métiers comme les
éboueurs
il n'y a pas de télétravail potes donc
c'est tous les jours au quotidien il se
lève à 3h pour commencer leur service à
4 heures du matin qu'en est-il de et du
mouvement vous disiez que la grève
n'était pas terminée elle aurait pu
l'être hier mais c'est pas le cas
pourquoi tout à fait donc nous avons
fait des propositions dans le sens où on
veut les agents veulent une meilleure
reconnaissance par le régime
indemnitaire
bien sûr ils veulent travailler par des
groupes de travail pour une meilleure
optimisation des tournées et pour les
conditions de travail
mais ce que vous êtes entendu on a
compris vos revendications est ce que
vous êtes entendu il ya eu une
proposition qui a été faite sur
une meilleure organisation du travail
avec un contact avec l'emploi le
constructeur de ces véhicules parce que
les matches qui n'est mécanisé les
camions médicalisée à prat latéral ne
fonctionne pas ça a créé beaucoup de
désagréments
et nous comme lui aussi c'est surtout
parce que dans cette collectivité qui
compte environ 400 gajan il faut savoir
il ya à peu près un tiers de
contractuels il demande aussi que les
contractuels soient pérennisés voir ce
eliseu stage et reese et à mesure ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi bien sûr humain
et qui a pris une ampleur dans les deux
premiers jours qui ont suivi l'appel à
la grève
c'est que même les contractuels sont
venus alors que leur disait de delajoux
est vraiment là qui la vie sauve venu
nous a dit qu'il voulait être gréviste
rendez compte des contractuels quoi et
la population locale
est-ce qu'elle a elle a soutenu l le
comprends ce mouvement de grève des
éboueurs
alors nous allons bien sûr auprès de la
population de cette communauté
d'agglomération on s'excuse on l'a fait
savoir par communiqué de presse de tous
les désagréments qui peuvent que ça peut
lire à l'intérieur de nos collines il y
à peu près 100 tonnes par jour et qui
sont dans les rues et oui la population
de moustiques chèque en blanc que trois
sites
aujourd'hui on nie pas pour les bloquer
parce que quasiment 95% de ce service
qui compte 160 agents sont en grève
donc quel plus besoin de les bloquer
j'utilise si ce n'est comme celle acte
de présence
et oui la population nous soutiennent
franchement le voit sur les réseaux
sociaux
il ya là même qui s'arrête en voiture
sans koné chez à perdre je dirais pour
nous donner de l'argent pour que les
agents puissent améliorer l'ordinaire du
midi quoi merci beaucoup serge s'ouvrira
d'avoir répondu ce matin on dirait que à
nos questions sur arte france